[Music]
my name is Cindy I'm a developer
advocate at Google cloud and today we're
going to talk about world scale
microscopy all up didn't it so yeah this
is jump right into it this is a somewhat
advanced kubernetes talk if you're here
I expect you to know what docker is yeah
okay what containers and orchestrators
and things like that okay we're good
you're in the right room so we're going
to architect an app from start to finish
it has to work around the world store
state be fast and a new term I just
invented called low ops because it's not
no ops right and we only have an hour to
talk about it yeah so what are we going
to do means memes are the best these
very illegal approved memes of course
I'm going to give a caveat
everything you see here could have built
built in a static JavaScript page and
launched in a CDN and being globally
distributed but you know what I wanted a
good micro-services example and hello
world just doesn't cut it we need to
build something somewhat real but not
too complicated and so a little meme
generator seemed right up the alley and
so here's the agenda right we're going
to talk about what we're building and
then we're going to go with the
stateless part in the stateful multi
cluster and then configuration and then
my favorite category other stuff
overview so how are we going to do this
we're going to do something that looks
like this
we're going to have six different micro
services there's five on the screen but
this is secret sixth one and when the
user comes to our landing page they're
going to come in to the web server and
the web server will just hit the reddish
cache it'll get the list of ten images
and show it they Chimel will be served
and the images will be pulled from GCS
regional buckets right makes perfect
sense when you want to make a new meme
it gets a little bit more complicated
again the request comes into our web
server and that would talks to the meme
creator microservice
and all this does is generate a JPEG and
stream it back to the web server now at
this point it's just going to stream
that JPEG straight back to the user
right very very fast we're not waiting
for it to be stored anywhere we're not
waiting for replication nothing at the
same time we're going to send it to the
image store service now the image store
service is the one that's going to send
it to the regional bucket store the
image there and get the link back now
it's going to take that and the metadata
that was used to generate the image and
put that into the cache and into the
MongoDB database now unfortunately
unlike cloud spanner MongoDB does not
you know become consistent around the
world magically in fact it's very
inconsistent so we're going to run it in
one cluster instead of all the clusters
right so these are all local clusters
that we're running and the MongoDB
database is in one of the clusters only
so we have to have some sort of cross
cluster service discovery as well and
then search for search it's a little bit
simple again the web request comes in we
talked to the image store service with
the requested terms it talks to MongoDB
for the links it gets those links and it
serves it from the appropriate regional
bucket so the interesting thing here is
the search is around the world right if
you generate a meme in Japan and still
stored in our Tokyo bucket you can still
find it in the United States but the
reddest cache is local to the local
cluster so this is a pretty reasonable
architecture nothing too complicated but
it's using six different microservices
which I find really fun and of course to
do this we're going to use the power of
kubernetes and we're going to use the
power of Google container engine oh yeah
it's the only way I'm going to ever wear
this shirt like who invented this thing
it's like half the shirt is that logo
right so here we go I gotta wear that
cloud next so let's start easy stateless
I expect most people in the audience to
know exactly what I'm going to do here
so the meme creator server is
a great example of a stateless app all
it does is taken a few you know simple
parameters and return a JPEG 100% state
list and config list as one API a get
with URL parameters no dependencies it's
a single standalone dr container so
here's the things we need to run the
stateless service the first is the
concept of a pod again this is more 101
but we had to learn this to go further
right so you have a group of one or more
containers that share localhost and are
always scheduled together right they all
share the same IP they live and die
together then we have deployments and
basically this says I want some many
pods to run what the pods need and the
deployment can takes care of the rest
using the replica set and we have a
service and because we can have
arbitrary number of pods we need a
stable endpoint to do service discovery
and load balancing so if you look at the
meme crater service and deployment it
looks something like this you have a
bunch of pods with a random ID and let's
say I want three of them when I have a
request come in to the meme creator
service
it'll round-robin load-balanced to
available pot that's it if a pod dies
it'll be replaced by a new one with the
new ID
we don't regenerate pods and so that's
very basic this is a hello world of
kubernetes let's go to a quick demo and
I'll also record my screen just in case
cool so here we have I'm going to run a
deployment with two replicas with the
nginx image and open up port 80 so our
deployment is created very easy what
does that look like something like this
now this is the folio of course in real
life you would write a lot less I can
see that I have two available replicas I
have two replicas in my spec port 80s
open images nginx exactly what we
specified in the command
now what I'm going to do is expose that
using a load balancer so I'm going to go
cube CTL expose and the nginx deployment
and type load balancer this of course as
most of you know will spin up a Google
cloud TCP load balancer and TCP load
balancers are not global they're very
reasonable and you can see that the
nginx deployment it's been created but
it the external IP is still pending
so in a few seconds we'll get that
external IP let's go fun waiting game
we're going to be doing this a lot
it's not even exciting I'm going to keep
going can you switch back to the slides
I'll show you that later all right cool
so then IPO to come and we would have
seen hello world from nginx very
exciting not really so let's go to
something a little bit more exciting a
little bit more complicated so stateful
right containers can have state and the
best example of this is MongoDB database
we're not running that this in GCE we're
not running this somewhere else we're
running it in kubernetes but there's
problems there are serious problems with
this especially if you try to do it with
a deployment and replica sets a MongoDB
replica set not to be confused with
kubernetes replica sets are complicated
to set up and are complicated to keep
running every single instruction on like
MongoDB website requires you to log into
a machine connect to the [ __ ] D client
do some commands here and there set up
your RS comp do all this complicated
stuff turns out in kubernetes land
excess aging is not something you do
right it requires high availability and
performance a database can't go down
it's very hard for it to recover things
like that and it has to have
high-performance SSDs things like that
of course obviously needs to store
persistent data otherwise it call it
database but MongoDB is not cloud native
a lot of databases can kind of deal with
node failure deal with new member
edition deal with all this kind of non
non cloud stuff I mean cloud stuff very
easily
MongoDB sadly cannot it really depends
on hosts and it can't be load balanced
at least not easily you should really
connect to all members of the replicas
set you can't connect to a load balancer
service and have the requests push
through like a proxy you can but it's
not native again so what we're going to
do is use a few things that were
released in the latest version of
kubernetes as especially causally called
stateful sets so the first thing we're
going to talk about our persistent
volumes these are data volumes that
persist even if the pod restarts or
moves then we have sidecar containers
that spits the container that helps a
primary container do its job so we'll
take a look at why we need that
with MongoDB then we have stateful sets
which are basically a set of pods that
can scale horizontally just like replica
sets but each pod maintains a consistent
Network and disk identity so this means
that if you lose pod - you'll get pod -
back and it will attach the same disk
that it had previously which is very
important for databases and finally the
last piece of puzzle is a headless
service which is a service that does no
load-balancing but instead exposes the
pods directly with their own DNS names
so what we have here is our headless
service and our [ __ ] DB stateful set
the first thing that happens is if a
volume does not exist for that pod
it will provision a volume for you then
it'll spin up the pod and the [ __ ] Dee
instance will store its data in that
volume and then we say I want three of
these so it does three of this for us
cool
now what happens is the configuration
sidecar is a little node.js process that
actually has a kubernetes API built into
it so it'll talk to the headless service
to discover the other members of the
MongoDB replica set now this is really
cool this means we don't have to
actually configure MongoDB manually
instead we just have the sidecar Auto
configure or cluster for us so once it
talks and figures out the rest of the
members it'll create the replica set for
us automatically
and when our app wants to talk to the
MongoDB replica set it bypasses the
headless service and talks directly to
the pods so the first pot is called
[ __ ] 0 [ __ ] [ __ ] 1 [ __ ] and [ __ ] 2
[ __ ] right we're not talking to the
[ __ ] service we're talking to each pod
directly using the headless service all
right can you switch back sweet so at
this point however IP we can obviously
go there but you can take my word for it
it works here you go that's an error
that's great I think I know all right
did I do something wrong who knows it's
not interesting let's just keep going so
I'm going to watch make state full one
and I was too lazy to even copy the yam
well so I have to eat from github
directly so the first thing I'm doing is
creating this thing called the storage
class and a storage class is not
technically necessary but I like it
because I can control what kind of disk
gets provisioned and I really want an
SSD so I made a new storage class called
fast that provisions kubernetes it makes
queries aware of the GCE persistent disk
and makes you able to provision SSDs
on-the-fly which is nice and now I'm
actually going to create the MongoDB
service and here's what happens you can
see that we have our [ __ ] - 0 spinning
up but we don't have the other two
replicas this is because a stateful set
actually spins up the pods one at a time
and if you think about it this is really
important for most traditional databases
because the replica set has to be
created first before a member can join
and so what this ensures is that you
don't have two people thinking that
they're both the primary and then you
have their reelection zand things like
that instead we wait till the first
container is created before starting the
next one and before starting the next
one obviously the first step is to
actually create those persistent disks
so you can see that we have three
persistent disk being created already
and they're bound to our our nodes so we
have storage [ __ ] zero storage Mangal
one and storage [ __ ] - now the other
thing to notice is the [ __ ] service
itself so we have our nginx deployment
on the very bottom that has a cluster IP
and an external IP the [ __ ] service has
a none for cluster IP now you might
think that's kind of weird and it is
it's because it's a headless service
there is no load balancer for the [ __ ]
service we don't need it instead it
exposes the pods [ __ ] 0 [ __ ] one among
go to directly to our application
okay now let's just go back to the slide
so we'll let that create in the
background see if this works
no listen twerk oh it's the wrong guy
wrong copy/paste
see that's why there we go see it works
no one can see it no one can see it can
you switch back I want to show people
that I actually did this I'm just
talking to myself here there see ha ha
ha I win all right let's go back all
right so if you want to learn more about
how to do that a little bit more deep I
have a blog post on the kubernetes blog
you can go to that short link to learn
more or to search for that I mean
there's a good search engine out there I
heard and it'll give you that I go into
pretty much exactly what I did but in
detail I explain what the yeah moles do
I explain what the sidecar does all that
kind of good stuff
ok so now let's talk about in my opinion
the most interesting thing why is it my
opinion the most interesting things so
it's the latest thing I've done right so
new is always interesting here's the
deal I have friends in Azure I have
friends in AWS public clouds all of them
have data centers around the world look
look at how many there are this is like
dot dot dot dot dot dot like you can't
even count them right um and we just
launched three more today right
California Canada and the last one which
I forgot that's ok um they're all very
important don't worry but the thing is
there's so many of them do you know how
many people do this so many people do
this they just say we're going to go to
production in one zone in one with one
provider and I'm telling you I have
again I know people do this on PCP I
have friends at a table yes they say the
same thing happens there it's like
because why why because it's hard right
yeah multi-region is hard multi-cloud is
hard but is 2017 we can do better than
this and kubernetes is really trying to
make it easier but it's still hard it's
still hard don't get me wrong but we
have to do this otherwise when
pod provider goes down for any reason
and we all do things just break right
with I saw great blog post saying you
know because of kubernetes they live
with the s3 outage they failed over just
seamlessly without any sort of downtime
because they had this redundancy and
this happens to everyone right it's not
just AWS or Google it's everyone has
downtime so with kubernetes you can
really hedge against that so we're going
to talk about two things the first thing
is the Federation control plane and it's
basically a service that manages the
global state of all the federated
clusters and when everyone says control
plane all it means is global state
management right it's like a global
variable that's managed somewhere it's a
fancy word for that and the really nice
thing that came out recently is the cube
fed tool how many of you have heard of
this or used it before people cool so if
you've ever setup cluster map federated
clusters before it was a pain you deploy
all these yeah meals and config maps and
all the stuff with the cube set tool
it's a few lines and the cube fed and
done so almost that's why I'm here
talking about it right so we're gonna
take a look at that can we switch to the
demo all right so what I'm going to do
is I have a huge make file that looks
something like this it's beautiful and
we're going to talk about some things we
have to do before we can get started so
the first thing is federated clusters
require DNS and this is because if you
wanted to cross cluster service
discovery you have to and especially
cross crowds cross cloud service
discovery say that 10 times fast you
have to have a DNS system that can route
traffic over the public Internet even if
you're using private DNS you still need
DNS and so oh hello ok ok weird
can i unplug this and plug it back in or
what should I do right now I'm confused
I keep talking so anyway you need DNS
things like that unplug this real fast
so what we're going to do is actually
use Google Cloud DNS to configure our
clusters and I'll plug it back in yeah
there we go so I'm kind of oh man oh all
right everyone gather around we'll just
look at my laptop well there we go
cool so right now I have basically I
bought a domain name called a world
class micro-services com because it's
very long and no one likes long domain
names so they're cheap and right now it
has nothing it's just a few name servers
and that's it but what I'm going to do
is I've created manage zone and I've
given it a name so now kubernetes can
actually connect to that now what we're
going to do is actually use a cube fed
tool to deploy Federation there we go so
that's the line we're going to run cube
fed in it and this is the name of our
federated context which is world-scale
micro-services and we're going to give
it a host cluster now this is really
interesting
we're actually hosting the controller
for the multi federated clusters inside
of a cluster so it's self hosted so
you're not wasting any resources with
another host controller kind of thing
it's actually hosting it inside one of
its own clusters which is really cool
and the last thing is we're going to
pass it that DNS zone name in fraud that
world-scale microservices comm dot very
important to put that last dot there we
don't it's not going to work
I learnt that the hard way so the next
thing we're going to do is actually oh
my gosh all right we're going to join
all the clusters into our federated
service and what we're going to do is
just loop through all the clusters that
we have and here's the clusters that we
have I've made one in all our public
data centers that you can launch
something in today so Asia East Asia
North East West Central East and East
West whatever why do I have to West I
have no idea okay weird okay a non
federated is what I was running the
other demos in I understand what's going
on but that's okay so right now we've
had our control plane deployed and it's
running our API server at that API that
I P address so now what I'm going to do
is just loop through all the different
clusters and run the cube fed join
command and this will just dump a bunch
of crap on the screen but that's okay
I'll look at the first one so it says
cube cat cube fed contacts world-scale
micro-services so that's our federated
context join cluster and the cluster the
new cluster is going to be cluster Asia
and North East one then we're going to
give it the cluster context and the host
cluster context and that's basically all
you do and it's automatically joined
into the cluster so now if I go keep CTO
let me do this
we hope so you can see that we have all
six of our clusters up and ready right
and you had to run with the context of
world scale micro services which is a
virtual you know federated context cool
okay so now there's one more step which
is very critical to get this working and
that is actually updating the DNS
controllers in all of our clusters so
right now all the clusters just
understand themselves they don't
understand the outside world it's a big
scary place what we want to do is make
it so that they connect to that new DNS
manager zone that we created right infra
roll scale micro-services calm domain
zone and use it so to do that before we
had you a bunch of complicated stuff
patch the kubernetes dns all those
concurrency stuff now all we have to do
is deploy a config map which I'll talk
about more later so I'm gonna create a
config map it basically says the
Federated domain is that infrared scale
micro-services comm and now I'm going to
sleep for 20 seconds and do something
really weird I'm going to kill all the
DNS pods
why because DNS is sticky and I want to
make sure that they all die and we re
get the new DNS configuration I'm 100%
sure if this is needed but it works well
so you know if it works do it right so
I'm just going to go through every
single cluster and delete cube DNS and
because it's running under a replication
controller it just spins up another one
right easy I don't have to care cool so
now we're done we have set up a
federated six federated clusters around
the world we just set up six better
clusters around the world there we go
all right can we switch back to the demo
are nothing to the slides so you might
be wondering why didn't I just make a
really big cluster that disband a whole
world why did I go at the second one
that looks a lot more complicated and
looks like Christmas it's because
reasons and the reasons are what is that
VM on the left is in Australia and the
other VM is in Singapore well they
probably shouldn't talk to each other if
there's a closer one right with and what
happens if this just dies
what is the cluster dies all services
around the world just die right with the
second option even if the global control
plane goes down all the local clusters
are still up and running functional
fully functional right you just can't
address them at the global scale and the
little clusters go down it's okay
traffic will reroute intelligently to
available clusters how would something
like this so if service a the app wants
it connect to service a obviously it'll
connect to the one in the cluster but
who wants it connect to service C it'll
say hey there's nothing available in the
cluster let me go to another cluster
that's pretty cool this means that you
don't have to have your services running
in every cluster if it's not a highly
used service in fact we'll talk about
something like that in this part right
now because if you go to my website comm
from there probably want to go to the
South Paulo data center not somewhere
else right in fact your users around the
world probably want to go to the data
center closest to them but they all want
to just type in my website comm it's
super annoying when I have to type in my
website dot uk' or my website dot
whatever right
I just want to type in my website comm
and get the fastest result turns out we
have this this is an actual map actual
map those black points are actually our
points of presences around the world
which means that if you connect to one
of these you're routed
thematically using Sdn networking right
so we have in any caste system to the
closest data center what this means is
every single one of these points of
presence broadcasts the same IP address
and the user connects to the closest one
automatically this means you're not
worrying about like DNS configuration or
anything like that you say I have one IP
Google you take care of the rest
and so how do you do that again
federated ingress this is a native of
kubernetes l7 load balancer and router
and it's federated which means that yet
one IP address for all of your clusters
and the way you do this on Google cloud
of course is the HTTP load balancer now
this is our global l7 load balancing
solution with a single IP address ssl
offload and in alpha ipv6 support which
is really really good so let's take a
look at how that works so what I'm going
to do is just deploy all my micro
services right now so I'm going to say
deploy deployment deploy service the
first thing I wanna do is Redis all
right here we go boom then I'm going to
do main demean creator suite then I'm
going to do what else do I have I don't
even know let's see I'm going to do the
website so it's our web front-end and
we're good to go now I'm also going to
deploy our MongoDB stack and because
it's only in one cluster it's a little
bit different
and we're going to deploy this little
thing called database helper which I
will talk about in a second sweet now if
I do a make get service it's going to
loop through all the clusters and get
all the services so you can see that
with just those commands it basically
federated all of these tasks into all
six clusters right I ran it on the world
scale micro Services context and because
that's a virtual federated context it
automatically distributed all the pods
into all the clusters right I didn't
have to log into each one and deployed
so of course what we want to do now is
to ingress so let's do that okay so can
we go back to the slides for one second
perfect thank you this is all I need to
do for ingress and this creates that
global load balancer you can see that
looks really simple except for one line
that weird line that says kubernetes
Iowa slash ingress Global static IP
named kubernetes ingress so this is
because we need to actually give it that
one static IP address otherwise it'll
all try to bring its own and this was
really simple to do can we switch back
to my laptop all I had to do was this
where is it
let's see ingress which is somewhere
here g-cloud compute addresses create
Cabrini's English - - global this will
create a global IP address for me on
Google cloud once I do that I can use
this kubernetes ingress in my kubernetes
natively I don't have to actually go
ahead and click any buttons on the UI or
anything like that so now if we go back
to our networking with pet edge right
here this networking page you can see
that I have these TCP load balancers
being created and those are for the
database helper which I'll get to in a
second but we also have this suite HTTP
load balancer created and so you can see
that we have all our backends
automatically added to it
of course it's not healthy yet it's
still spinning up and each one of them
has just this one IP address so run make
get ingress you can see that all of my
clusters all have the same IP address
for the service all over the world and
it's probably still spinning up but
let's try it still spinning up that's
okay now we'll wait for that and when
that's going up we'll just go back to
the slides real fast and talk about
configuration because why not easy
coding right why is there no term called
easy coding these are interesting but
the regional buckets for a lot of people
they want their data to be regional they
don't want to be distribute around the
world sure you get a little bit less
uptime but you want to be cheaper maybe
mostly for memes who want to pay for
memes and you want it to be regional so
it's faster but where how do you know
which bucket - right - right
your Central Asia East Mars oh wait
that's a week sorry oops no we're not
Mars data center it's a rumor or not we
don't have one of those you could do
something like this you can get the
current zone dynamically because GCE
will report what data center is running
in and then you have this huge mapping
table saying if I'm running in US West
1a then use bucket one and oh my gosh
every time you add something new right
let's say you want to add s3 into this
well okay you gotta go edit it right and
that sucks what if you could just do
this just use the environment variable
and automatically get it that sounds
good to me so what we're going to do is
use a config map to store that
information so this is basically a some
configuration information that's exposed
to a container either as an environment
variable or file and then a secret is
basically an config mat but off it's
gated there's a lot of debate in the
community over it's not encrypted yes
it's not encrypted you can use vault
kelsey has a great
tutorial on how you can use vault to
make truly encrypted secrets but yeah
right now the default thing is just
obfuscated just to keep in mind all
right so let's go back to the demo at
this point I hope it's up let's see
there we go
awesome so here is my thing so you can
see that it's detecting that it's
running in the US West Zone obviously
because we're in California and here I
have this interesting website that I
hope works because it's not mine called
geo screenshot and I'm going to take a
screenshot of this IP address from
Germany Singapore and New York let's go
okay can can people know it no one can
see that right let me try to zoom in you
can see from from Germany it's your West
which makes sense from Singapore it's
Asia East which makes sense and from New
York it's us East so yeah this is
actually really working and if you see
use on YouTube it's not going to work
because I'm going to turn the service
off so don't even try it but it works
and it's really cool so obviously here
we're going to be in the West Coast I
can't shake my location Google is pretty
smart about that so we're going to use
the West Coast buckets so what I want to
do is do this thing called set up
buckets and it's on a fail fail fail
fail fail why because I already did it I
kind of because if nothing would have
actually launched if I didn't have the
config map if you don't have a config
map and deployment depends on that
config map it'll actually be pending
until that config map is deployed this
makes a lot of sense what I did is I
made a different configure with the same
name and then all it does if you can
switch back to the slides keep picking
up the wrong one all right all it does
is it gives the bucket name for that
region right but you can see
everything's the same except that actual
value of the bucket name so the first
one would go in a US east datacenter so
a dash East that's for America East I
guess and a dash West I'm not very
creative with names is America West
and if we can go back - yep thank you if
you go to our cloud storage browser you
can see I have basically a bucket for
all of my regions and I have this test
bucket so the test bucket is a multi
regional bucket that I was using
originally you can see that the the
regions are actually local to that data
center which is really cool
versus the multi-regional bucket is for
that region so if we go into our uswest
bucket you can see that it's currently
empty now let's make a meme my friend
Cameron has generously donated his
beautiful dog and cat so they say
poppers are the best and create and we
get a pupper but we don't get a pepper
yeah no pepper what's going on
oh oh I freaked out
why did not work because I don't have my
image creator sir like image store so
it's just not even storing any images
got to do that deployment deploy service
from each store there we go sweet now
let's do it get pods make sure that's up
and running here we go got a little
crash loopback Oh interesting so our
image sort of service is creating I have
a bad feeling I can't access docker hub
from here huh interesting
so basically our MongoDB pod is not
creating which is really interesting
it's dependent on docker hub everything
else is not so I wonder what's going on
but and this is why this is crash loot
back offing because the database helper
is trying to connect to our MongoDB
replica set which is not existing that's
okay so we can see our image store
service is creating the nice thing about
micro services is that they can fail or
you know with some grace let's refresh
that here we go you can see that because
the image store service is up and
running those requests got created
um man come on guys who is that
clouds angry at you and if you go to
this website you can make memes sure go
ahead
just do it but because MongoDB is down
the searching will not work the
interesting thing is all of these memes
once [ __ ] comes back up will be saved
and we'll talk more about that in a
second but around the world these will
be stored in different buckets and here
if we refresh our bucket here we go
a bunch of people are making memes if
anyone puts anything inappropriate I
hope my mommy won't try alright alright
we're not we're going to close the
website there we go not tempted alright
so if you can go back to the slides
please cool so it's not other stuff
let's go back um and this is like I
think the most important part of the
talk everything else is great it's
really like wow we did stuff right but
this took me basically all January to
make by myself right all six
microservices and I kind of learned a
lot about building microservices the
first thing you had think about is this
sink versus a sink so synchronous
point-to-point communication right it's
pretty easy to do I think kubernetes
really makes it easy to do more than
just normal if you have your app and it
wants to talk to a service it just you
know makes a request to the service and
that automatically load balances to
available pod and the pod gives it back
it doesn't go through the service I
don't know why I did that it goes
directly to the pod but it's pretty easy
right I don't have to worry about the
how many pod to have or anything I just
hit the service and we're good to go
this can be done with the REST API can
but with ER PC or any other RPC
framework either way like service
discovery is basically free right and it
feels native to kubernetes here I would
have three tweets that say like you
can't do micro services with sync but
legal wouldn't let me put tweets on my
slide so it's blank
just imagine the tweets there right and
angry people saying you have to have a
sink otherwise it's just a distributed
monolith and I kind of agree and kind of
disagree with that this is why the async
kind of looks like your pod put
something into a work queue the the
other pods just kind of read from that
work you finish the work and maybe put
it into another queue for the first pod
to consume and so if you look at our
architecture for creating a new meme I
feel that these two pieces really fit
the async nature why because if I say
create a meme enter and nothing comes
out it's broken it doesn't matter if it
comes out in like 10 seconds async does
not matter it has to be synchronous I
want it now right to do the lifetime of
the request it has to finish however
storing the image in the back end needs
to actually finish it can't fail right
so that needs to be asynchronous and it
doesn't matter about performance as much
real like in the request the lifetime of
the request instead it matters that it
gets done eventually and it gets done
consistently so what I did is database
helper is actually listening to a pub
sub topic and this pub sub topic is
getting requests from image store and
once that request comes in the database
helper is talking directly to MongoDB
and putting it in but the other way
around when you want to query the
database that's a synchronous service
the database helper exposes a restful
interpret interface and I query MongoDB
through that rest proxy do not expose
your MongoDB to the Internet do it and
use passwords people please please
please
so Google cloud pub/sub is an
asynchronous message queue many-to-many
communication fully managed you know
it's no ops server list it just scales
to millions and messages instantly you
don't have to warm it up or anything
like that there's a G RPC API that's
really fast and a REST API that you can
use as well and the bunch of libraries
for about 10 languages the normal 10
languages
support on Google cloud so before I go
to the next one this is I think really
important to understand why you want
something like this if you've ever had
this why I said you know those service
those those memes won't be stored in
MongoDB now because the database is down
but they'll be buffered in pub/sub
waiting for the database helper to come
back up and read from them and then
they'll all come in so even though I had
database downtime it's still safe
sitting in pub/sub and of course I mean
I work for Google cloud I recommend
using one of our managed databases but
for a lot of people they want to run
their own so I'm not going to make any
judgments they're only a little bit so
the other thing I want to talk about are
the stack driver tools when even to a
stack driver talk today okay fair amount
I like them a lot mostly for something
like this logging was pretty important
now it's not the most beautiful log
viewer but when you have six
microservices on time six clusters right
that's looking to the math for me the
answer is 36 36 different services
running around the world right with the
stack driver logging I was able to take
all of those into one centralized of
viewpoint I can go to any of my clusters
any of the containers in my clusters and
see the logs right there something I
didn't think I would use but ended up
using because I'm really bad at writing
code was tracing so this is a trace
graph this is an actual trace from one
of my requests who can see the really
weird what in the world was going on
thing there I was actually not closing a
stream correctly
I was never returning and so the process
would just start again
after 30 seconds and so you can see that
really weird it's kind of blurry on the
screen but it goes for female like
hundred milliseconds hunter milliseconds
300 milliseconds to 30,000 milliseconds
and then a few hundred milliseconds
right so that was clearly something
broken and I could not figure it out but
when I saw it in this trace I was like
really really easy and excited right and
no js' except moon crater which is in
PHP interesting fact it's just Google
cloud dot like start trace one line of
code to get all this information which
is really
and then there's so much more yeah
this is a small list that mean a
co-worker created over drinks one day
and we're like wow there's a lot of
stuff to talk about but microservices
everyone says they're easier than
monoliths and something something
something or I don't know whatever but
you have to think about a lot of things
when you're really doing them so people
are taking pictures this is like this is
just a random list guys this is not real
um I'm kidding you take your pictures
take your pictures of this so if you
want if you want to learn more about
mercury services with us me and my
coworker ray sang who's another cloud da
we want to create a new blog post slash
video series this is this is me saying
it now so I'm forced to do it later
follow us on medium and Twitter and
hopefully we'll announce something later
this year the two of us kind of sat down
and we're like wow there's so many
unknown knowns known unknowns unknown
known knowns and like who knows what's
going on in this world of microservices
a lot of people are talking about it
let's get practical let's just you know
try to work the community and understand
what we want to do
[Music]
you